so here's some stats that you to
validate your point then and now
portugal drug
decriminalization
in 1999 they had 369 overdose in 2016
was 30 in 2000 they had 907 hiv
diagnosis through injection now it's 18
99 people incarcerated was 3863 911 40
and 17. so question how different is
portugal than oregon
um you know we don't have enough stats
yet for oregon
in order to quantify this you know it is
obviously organ uh past measure 110
and we'll see because i think that you
know
as much as i'm a firm believer in
sensibly regulating all drugs because
i'd rather have the government in charge
of potency in the fda and those and you
know
officials
but full decriminalization like oregon
has done
is i think going to be the wave of the
future because even last night in in
president biden's
speech for the first time we mentioned
harm reduction
and and for the first time i think that
we're actually going to be investing in
public health interventions
almost at the rate that we now do for
supply-side interdiction
patrick but portugal
legalized drugs no but they became they
became very very stringent
with the uh manufacturers of drugs
correct
they really control them in other words
they control the amount of drugs that
these pharmaceutical companies
were manufacturing and selling and so
they totally didn't legalize drugs
because you're still controlling the
manufacture production and sales of
dangerous drugs even though they did
decriminalize the use as as
the lady who had stated
but they didn't totally legalize it
either well and and that's the what is
decriminalization what is legalization
what's sensible regulation there's a
continuum on the spectrum and i think
you know finding that you know that that
perfect fit
i don't think you're ever going to see a
heroin store at the corner of you know
fifth and main in america but you will
have heroin assisted treatment programs
that are much more efficacious so for
example in switzerland i mean this is
this is not anything new is this has
occurred across the world in many
aspects in switzerland heroin assisted
treatment programs basically
the empirical science
directly reflected a drop in crime
with from people who
were in the program
people got off welfare they reintegrated
into their families their communities
and so we know public health
interventions long term are much more
efficacious than using the hammer of the
criminal justice system if you enjoyed
this short clip give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to watch the whole thing click over here